as germany clears up the firefighters of
arvila face a grim challenge every
minute
they pump 12 000 liters of water from a
flooded
underground car park but it's not the
water that's worrying them
when the flood first came locals saw
plenty of people running into the car
park
but they didn't see many coming out
again we think that there are
40 50 cars in that in the second level
and we are worried that we find some or
a lot
people in their cars
the prospect of more deaths hangs
heavily across germany a nation
still in shock so while the firefighters
continue
their search of the flooded garage
behind me fearful
of what they might discover this town
this region
is struggling to come to terms with the
devastation wrought by these
floods this is germany one of the
richest most sophisticated countries in
the world
and it has been brought to its knees by
nature
the historic center of arvala is
normally a tourist attraction but now
look at it
debris piled more than six feet high the
road's full of
thick clinging mud there is
a sense of camaraderie here but it's
blended with bewilderment and even
helplessness on the edge of town is
krista's
wrecked apartment possessions ruined and
now discarded
her son tells us the insurance won't
cover this his mother
in her 80s has nothing
as for the river that caused all this
pain and suffering it now flows benignly
but the scars remain bridge is broken
roads ripped up lizards has lived by the
river for six decades
she remembers one previous flood but
nothing like this where the water
reached
so high in her house
here
a stranger's van now lies in her garden
tossed there by the water
cars are strewn around this town germany
is a resilient nation
but the damage the pain the repair bill
they'll all be daunting adam parsons sky
news
available